le doy un 5 tal vez porque me miran a mí
11 contra 1 calificando 11 chicos le
pedimos a angela que calificará a 11
chicos en persona
cómo te sientes estoy muy emocionada
pero también nerviosa cuando hablas con
tus amigas sobre chicos alguna vez los
califican no con un número pero
definitivamente juzgamos un podcast
lista para calificar algunos chicos hoy
claro suena bien hagamos digamos los hay
dios hay puedo escucharlos dios mío que
hice
i
bien chicos encantado los chicos pueden
ponerse los audífonos
a todo volumen empezando por el chico de
la izquierda quiero que lo califique en
una escala del 1 al 10 según su
apariencia física muy bien lista así
muy bien le daré un 4 por su apariencia
no es alguien a quien me acerca de una
rumba apariencia 4 el segundo chico es
atractivo pero me da vibras de chico de
fraternidad 7 me parece amigable pero
también rudo lo cual me gusta 8 no me
mires no no es necesariamente mi tipo de
hombre 6
el siguiente chico es un 44 parece muy
amigable pero es un poco bajo 5 el
siguiente es como un 3 una de mis manías
es que tienen que ser más altos que yo
el sonrío me gusta su figura siento que
se cuida 7 parece que sería bueno para
pasar el rato
con 44 luego el último chico también un
no me gustó esto está bien pero fue
bueno
angela ahora tiene tres minutos para
salir rápidamente con cada chico sin
poder verlos y para calificar sus
personalidades es temprano la cómo te
llamas hola mi nombre es julio soy
angela es un placer quería decirte que
eres muy bonita gracias alguna vez ha
sido el eaton kenyon no no he ido si
alguna vez tengo la oportunidad de
llevarte y te veo sonreír será la mejor
parte de la cita en realidad sonaba muy
bien pero no sentí la conexión que
buscaba no sentí nada de eso como crees
que calificarías esa cita 14 segunda
ronda personalidad 4 vista strings
sinceramente no me gustó mucho 2 una
buena cita jugar videojuegos y a los
bolos me gustan las bolas tu comida
favor la comida italiana amo el pan
buena respuesta creo que estaría
sonriendo todo el tiempo y le gusta el
pan 8 nuestro puntaje crediticio no sé
eso es malo si quiero decir deberías
conocerlo
cuál es tu puntaje crediticio bueno
siempre su mires como de 720 como
averiguo mi puntaje crediticio 6 es
tomar el incap como en un mes dura ocho
horas diablos buena suerte como un 66 no
creo que sea una mala persona es decir
soy más una buena persona alguien de
bien yo intentaba no reírme
7 te gusta el boba o si adora el boba
espera donde hay un lugar llamado
marugame en la costa sur que es bastante
bueno también la semana pasada y fuiste
allí el viernes es muy bueno bueno me
entusiasmó la idea de tener una primera
cita genial
9 me gusta mucho cocinar a mí también me
interesa la cocina cuál es tu plato
estrella de hecho estoy trabajando con
mi madre en ello el otro día hicimos una
llama la ya estuvo muy bien esta chamba
la haya zona muy bien
7 yo nací en filipinas y básicamente yo
nací ahí en serio
eres filipina genial deberíamos salir y
conocernos en realidad nunca he salido
con alguien de mí
cultura 7
ha sido a coachella últimamente no no
fui predigo que rihanna estará en la
cabeza del cartel el año que viene 4a
estudia ingeniería aeroespacial y
matemática impresionante no es tan bueno
ya estoy haciendo un pregrado en
biología enorgulleciendo a tus padres
creo que fue muy fácil hablar con él 8
hay una diferencia entre el chico el que
calificase con el puntaje más alto por
su apariencia y el del puntaje más alto
por su personalidad entienda si tienes
que elegir uno cuál eliges esto es muy
desesperante
quizás el chico de la personalidad
porque siento que si eres lindo pero no
puedo hablar contigo de nada entonces
cómo va a funcionar esto ganador
estás hablando con brandon de nuevo qué
tal me alegro de volver a hablar contigo
también me alegra me resultó divertido
conocerte yo también disfruto hablar
contigo entonces quieres que sigamos
conociéndonos sí y si quieres por
supuesto quieren verse cara a cara claro
es decir te he visto así que será una
sorpresa para ti muy bien pónganse de
pie
conocerte aprecio que calificar es mi
personalidad con lo más fácil es que
tenemos muchas cosas en común y sin luz
y hambre es brandon el chico con el que
te vería saliendo sabes que en cuanto a
la apariencia no pero en personalidad lo
califica muy alto así que estoy abierta
a ello supongo
cuando elijo las personas en un entorno
social todo es por las miradas porque no
llego a hablar con todos ellos
definitivamente cambió mi perspectiva en
cuanto a la forma de salir con alguien
aprecio que escogiera a la persona con
mayor puntaje en personalidad porque
puedes llegar a sentirse físicamente
atraído por ellas si sus personalidades
de línea muy bien quieres saber cómo te
calificó ella por tu apariencia claro te
calificó con un 3 por tu altura me
parece muy bien estaba al lado de chicos
bastante altos soy un símbolo sexual así
que ella te calificó con un 6 amigo
no soy yo símbolo sexual ya te dio el
puntaje más alto gracias a lo que no me
haya puesto un cero no te puso un cero
muy bien gracias a dios por tu
personalidad ella te calificó con un 9
así que fuiste más alto genial
el más bajo y el más alto o 18 no es
genial es decir doblamos justo ahí
voy a esperar a perder de tema
si tuvieras que elegir entre lo físico y
lo emocional
quiero decir hey si puedes hacerme reír
es el camino a mi corazón al principio
se trata mucho de la apariencia pero si
tienen una gran personalidad son más
atractivos digan lo que piensan en los
comentarios este fue un experimento con
diferentes episodios de contra uno y
queremos hacer todo tipo de cosas nuevas
digan lo que opinan sígannos en
instagram si quieren enterarse de las
actualizaciones y suscriban se den ya me
gusta y nos vemos jubilee vive
intensamente